[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sportwart dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist und reaktionär
ich bin selbst herr sportler und heute
zu gast beim sport report ferdinand
querfeld hallo hallo und sein bruder
rudolf querfeld servus alonso und ihr
zwei seit ruderer das heißt
gemeinsam sitzt die familie im selben
boot sondern auch sportlich im selben
boot
ihr fazit vierer ohne das erklärt sie
wir dann nachher was das dann genau ist
und was ihr daraus verstehen und jeweils
herbst 2020 bei der europameisterschaft
in polen und seit dort vierter geworden
irgendwie war das die
europameisterschaft war für uns ein
riesenerfolg
also viele denken vielleicht der vierte
platz so knapp an der medaille vorbei
aber wenn man sich unsere ergebnisse der
letzten jahre anschaut wird das für uns
ein riesen schritt in die richtige
richtung vor allem im hinblick für die
olympischen spiele
sonstige 21 und wir waren mit der
leistung sehr zufrieden haben alle
richtig viel spaß und man froh dass wir
eben diese einzige regatta im jahr wegen
dem corona wir es doch verein durften
und wir haben sehr genossen betrifft das
waren ja alles nicht einfache zeit davor
und auch danach nicht war die leistung
die er da abgeliefert hat überraschend
völlig überraschend ich weiß ich genau
überraschend war aber ist natürlich
somit habt das kannst du ja im dunklen
macht keiner keine wettkämpfe
wir haben sehr sehr hart trainiert das
wussten wir wir hatten auch sehr
schnelle zeiten während dem training und
am ende war mehr als glücklich dass
dieser welt kann man statt gefunden hat
weil so konnten uns testen international
mussten ein euro bestehen
wir haben beim drehen schon gewusst dass
wir sehr gut zusammen harmonieren das
brot gut läuft die trainer aber noch
sehr zufrieden und dann was echt cool
also wieder eben dann zeigen konnten was
wir drauf haben ist das ein wichtiger
faktor diese harmonie ferdinand zwischen
den vier männern die dem boot sitzen
wenn es noch mal an dem tag nicht passt
kann sich das auch wirklich auf die
entlastung aus witten absolut also viele
leute glauben vielleicht dass es im
rudern hauptsächlich im kraft geht
natürlich das kraftwerk wichtige
komponente aber technik und haben wir
nie ein umso größerer ich mein wenn wir
sagen schon wissen zwei meter groß 100
kilo schwer weil einer von diesen 100
kilometer nicht richtig im rücken
dort sind jetzt plötzlich 100 kilo gegen
das gut arbeiten und kleinigkeiten
machen eben auf zeigt damit ein
riesenunterschied
und deswegen ist der rhythmus und die
haben wir nie so extrem wichtig deswegen
trainieren wir auch sehr viele schläge
gemeinsam gut 1000 kilometer im jahr
der mit dem perfekt abgestimmt sind und
wie kann man sich das vorstellen
was kann da dazu führen dass das dann
plötzlich nicht funktioniert oder was
sind die kleinigkeiten die man an jenem
tag arbeiten kann damit das wirklich
dann funktioniert ja am tag an sich ist
ja schon bloß spielt also wenn es da am
tag vom wird doch nicht funktioniert da
hat man auf dem dringend davor nicht
wirklich gearbeitet
auf diesem auch ein bisschen nervös das
kann auch sein aber eine rudolstadt ist
eigentlich viel komplexer als man denkt
also man bewegt sich anbot
man muss den einsatz richtig treffen man
muss das blatt richtig aus dem wasser
führen alles komplizierter begriffe aber
man lernt dass er im laufe der jahre
aber das kann ein zentimeter im einsatz
vorne eine millisekunde zu langsam oder
hinten aus dem entzug ein bisschen zu
früh weg und das macht schon unterschied
aus und wenn das jetzt pro schlag
einzelne mieter ist gerechnet auf 2 150
schläge im rennen hat neben 150 cm
verloren quasi ja und das ist halt im
rudersport auf den ein unterschied der
halt dramatisches das summiert sich dann
und kann dann wahrscheinlich
entscheidend sein
rudolf jetzt habe ich gesehen dass
dieses training gemeinsam so essenziell
ist das stelle ich mir vor was in der
ganzen schwierigen pandemie zeit
wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach das zu
organisieren wie hat sich das gelöst
dass ihr da die notwendige routine
gemeinsam im boot haben konnte jetzt
also im märz glaube ich oder in der
februar kam eine lock down bei uns in
österreich und das war schon eine sehr
schwierige zeit das war ungewiss finden
die olympischen spiele 2020 york statt
haben wir überhaupt wettkämpfe und hat
jeder sportler für sich glaube ich schon
seine probleme gehabt zudem billige
struggled wir hatten dann haben wir die
guten möglichkeiten dann zu hause recht
viel zu trainieren also es gibt dem
ruderergometer also bruder maschinen
aber auch rad ergometer an der walze und
ich glaube wir haben das mentale echt
sehr sehr stark gemacht dass jeder von
uns hat sich selber zu hause gepusht und
ich habe den großen vorteil dass mit
meinen großen bruders mit dem fernsehen
zusammen wohnen
also hatte ich eigentlich jemanden
trainingspartner meiner seite und wir
haben auch versucht mit so meetings
online-meetings einfach uns gegenseitig
zu motivieren ergebnisse zu schicken und
zu pushen
und dann hat man glaube ich auch das
große glück in wien oder in österreich
generell dass wir aber april glaube ich
wieder aufs wasser gehen durften zuerst
einen kleinen boden also nun einer und
dann in weiterer folge als die zahlen
mit ein bisschen gesunken sind dadurch
können wir mit einem vier rudern und wir
haben diese schwierige zeit recht gut
gelöst gemeinsam und das anscheinend
auch gut funktioniert der vierte platz
bei der europameisterschaft hat das
bewiesen am tag sex die leistung zu
bringen
aber in der korona zeit in der pandemie
zeit war ja nicht nur dann in technik im
einsatz sondern hat auch als soldaten
gedient wie wir das für du dich dann für
dich werden
lustigerweise das hat man recht viel
spaß gemacht also einerseits war es toll
ob man etwas zurückzugeben wenn wir
nehmen diesen anspruch im bundesheer
jahr nehmen wir immer an und dann mal
etwas zurückgeben zu können einmal ganz
cool und wir haben im bei rewe in sein
lager gearbeitet und mussten dort quasi
sortiment an schlichten und die ersten
ein zwei tagen natürlich ungewohnt also
haben wir noch nie gemacht aber wir
wurden sehr gut aufgenommen um erhalten
recht spaß gemacht die arbeiten laufen
davor
und ja einmal bei rewe im lager
ausgeholfen auch wie war das für dich da
ferdinand da zu sehen dass man als
sportler gemeinsam mit anderen top
sportlerinnen und sportlern die
teilweise schon qualifiziert sind wie
olympia oder schon medaillen haben bei
großereignissen dort dann mitzuhelfen
regale zu schlichten und organisieren
wie ist es dir damit gegangen eigentlich
ganz gut aus dem ersten tag es gab ja in
diesem rebellenlager sehr viele stunden
am tag schicht also haben wir gehofft
dass wir eine schicht bekommen mit dem
er relativ gut trainieren können haben
auch geht also wir haben dann quasi vom
frühen mittag also früher nachmittag bis
späten nacht gearbeitet und durften in
der früh dann eben trainieren was aber
sehr interessant weil zuerst unsere
aufgabe nur dass wir ein schlichten
dürfen oder müssen und haben wir auch
gesehen wie viel eigentlich so ein
rebell ag steht und dann durften wir
auch die sache beruhigen dass dort
genügend klopapier hatten
da hatte sich einig kann das aufregen
müssen dass wir keine meinen geschäften
haben weil das war genügend klopapier
fort aber nachdem wir ein paar tage dort
von haben sie noch
mit mehr aufgaben belastet und durften
wir auch kommissionieren bedürften
dieser elektrischen wagen überfahren
haben unsere einkaufslisten bekommen und
dann dürften leben für die verschiedenen
supermärkten in wien und graz österreich
die einkaufslisten abarbeiten und das
war ein sehr angenehmer job vor allem
weil wir eben gemerkt wir können etwas
zurückgeben können neben aushelfen wo es
gerade gebraucht wird und es war zwar
nur ein paar tage weil hat sich die lage
relativ schnell normalisiert aber für
diese paar tage hatte ich großen spaß
wird und damit natürlich auch gezeigt
dass wir gut ausgebildet salz
heeressportler vereine grund wer zeit
ist ja noch gar nicht dass so lange her
weil du bist ja erst seit kurzem als
herr sportler beim härte was mich in
amerika dazu kommen wir dann auch gleich
hast du da irgendwas auch einsetzen
können was doing grund verdienste
gelernt hast ja vor allem teamwork also
beim herner sport also beim in der grund
wer zeit haben wir gemerkt wie wichtig
es ist auch als gruppe von fremden
leuten die wir dann auch quasi beim rebe
lager waren gut zu harmonieren gemeinsam
zu arbeiten an einem strang zu ziehen
und wie gesagt meine grund wird zeit
weil erst im november im jahr davor
das war relativ frisch ja aber einfach
diese arbeitswille und im was
zurückgeben zu können und quasi als team
als fremder menschen gemeinsam für ein
gutes ding so und trotzdem funktionieren
und dass das im team das ganze ja am
boot auch du warst in amerika hast dort
studiert auf der university of
california in berkeley als ein bachelor
in politik und ökonomie gemacht wie war
die zeit in amerika für dich und wie war
das auch aus sportlicher sicht dort für
dich ja eigentlich unglaublich weil
sowas merkt man also ich wurde damals
recruiter quasi ich wurde dann quasi
nach einer weltmeisterschaft gefragt ob
es mir spaß machen würde ob ich
interesse hätte nach amerika zu gehen
und hatte ich relativ viele angebote von
verschiedenen universitäten und haben im
endeffekt die university of california
berkeley gewählt im endeffekt weil es
eines der besten teams gibt den usa
akademischer von top niveau ist und
natürlich kalifornien das wetter hat auf
jeden fall ein riesenplus und habe ich
vier jahre studiert und auch die rudert
und das ist einfach an das man sich
vorstellen kann also
das ist einfach das sport und amerika
vor allem dieser college sport einen
riesen stellenwert so trainiert dort auf
dem team dessen 60 oder 70 ruderer
gecoacht von einem weltbesten olympia
coaches der usa
und man hat einfach nicht mehr dieser
5678 wenigsten wie man in österreich hat
sondern man müsse sich aber mit dem
besten nachwuchssportler der welt also
von grupotel jemanden u23-weltmeister
aus allen ländern
das hat mich finde ich ja sehr geprägt
also einerseits der studien anspruch
wird toll weil ich ihm in vier jahren
ein studium abschließen konnte und
währenddessen auf dem höchsten niveau
trainieren konnte andererseits arbeitet
freunde gefunden fürs leben auf der
ganzen welt und ich war zum ersten mal
allein weg von daheim und relativ weit
weg von zu hause und habe relativ
schnell erwachsen werden müssen und hat
dabei ein großartiger zeit dort viele
freunde gefunden tolles wetter und eben
ein abschluss gemacht und das
nicht-einhalten keiner mehr weg du bist
jetzt 24 und ein bruder ist 22 router
wäre das für dich ein thema nach amerika
zu gehen studieren oder ist gerade die
zielsetzung mit den sportlichen zielen
im 4
in dem sinne als priorität weiter vorne
gereiht ja ich habe mich gegen das
kapitel amerika entschieden
also ich hatte hätte auch die
möglichkeit gehabt ich war sogar eine
zeit lang auch ein halbes jahr ungefähr
in berkeley
auch bei meinem bruder das war für mich
einfach zu früh und nicht das richtige
also das war der moment 18 nach der
matura und ich habe das gefühl ich muss
mich mal ein bisschen selber finden habe
den schritt gewagt nach amerika und das
hat für mich nicht so gepasst wie ich
mir das vorgestellt habe und habe mich
für mich dass wir beschlossen dass dann
abzubrechen bin einer halben jahr wieder
zurückgegangen
und jetzt muss ich sagen ist die oberste
priorität einfach die qualifikation für
die olympischen spiele und da geht es
auch keine andere möglichkeit aus jetzt
hier ist sein und vollgas turnieren
draufsicht fokussieren weil das wieder
einem auch nicht geschenkt also worauf
auch viel viel kraft und zeit dafür
und wenn das kapitel mal wieder beendet
ist und abgeschlossen ist dann in
späterer folge könnte mir schon wieder
gut vorstellen im ausland vielleicht
noch ein studium anzuhängen
aber das ist zukunftsmusik muss ich
nachschauen und das jetzt die
olympischen spiele angesprochen was
fehlt euch da noch als 4 bis zur
qualifikation also wie es bis der weg zu
erfolgreichen qualifikation im jahr 2021
im mai findet für uns die internationale
kooperation noch statt
da gibt es noch zwei quotenplätze da
können sich alle boote weltweit die sich
noch nicht für die olympischen spiele
qualifiziert haben also in unserer
bootsklasse können danach ein olympia
ticket ergattern also wie gesagt noch
zwei plätze also es geht quasi um die
wurst
man sagt also sehr sehr knapp dran hänge
rennen wenn das werden und glaube sind
auf einem sehr guten weg als jetzt
erwartet uns noch ein harter winter wo
man sehr viel grundlage trainieren
müssen um bei unserer technik arbeiten
wir sind noch viel unterwegs auf
trainingslager und dann wollen wir mal
voll angreifen natürlich unser ziel ist
ein dass dieses tickets zu ergattern und
im laufrad folge daneben 2021 zum
beispiel nachdruck hier zu fliegen und
dort auch ein gutes ergebnis abzuliefern
und das wäre natürlich der größte traum
von uns und dafür arbeiten wir jetzt
jeden tag recht hart nach den nächsten
wochen auch recht hart und monate und
dann werden wir sehen was rauskommt für
uns man ferdinand was kann man sich
darunter vorstellen wenn dein bruder
gesagt wir arbeiten hart also konkrete
zahlen was bedeutet das genau
wie kann man sich den trainingsalltag in
dieser phase vor der qual ich so bei
euch vorstellen wie trainingsalltag die
folge steckt also man muss auch wenn an
dieser regatta in luzern wird auch auf
die regatta auf der genannt weil sie
quasi echt das härteste rennen ist dass
du alle vier jahre manchmal haben kannst
also wenn du dich noch nicht
qualifiziert hass und dort und dieser
regatta mussten dieses rennen da
vielleicht jeder also gibt es zu wenig
plätze und so viele boote den start
gehen da vielleicht die diese beiden
plätze ergattern
und wenn man dort sich qualifiziert hat
man auch bei möglichen spielen in der
regel gute karten weil dann ist man
wirklich richtig richtig stark deswegen
trainiert also wir müssen neuen trainer
robert senz der hat sofort in
deutschland viel erfolg gehabt und jetzt
ist alles schon nationaltrainer hast du
dann knappen dreivierteljahr und die
hatten wir uns nach der ostdeutsche
methode kreditzusagen
das heißt viel umfänge relativ niedriger
intensitäten dafür ein oder zwei tage
pro woche wo wir relativ hart arbeiten
aber wie gesagt viele und ränge fünf bis
sechs stunden am tag sechs bis sieben
tage der woche also wir schauen dass wir
pro woche im durchschnitt 30 stunden
kommen manchmal sogar mehr
der rover das ein großer verein vertritt
lagern also wir waren jetzt sogar in der
korona phase diesen sommer obwohl er
keine regatten hatten 16 wochen auf
trainingslager in österreich und italien
und werden jetzt im frühjahr wenn sich
die lage so weit normalisiert auch
wieder dreimal gefahren damit wir eben
perfekt an den umfang arbeiten könne
isoliert fokussiert auf die ziele
hinarbeiten können und damit leben im
meriva topfit sind und ja unterscheidet
sich das training auch dazu den
erfahrungen die die in amerika gemacht
hast das ist ein großer unterschied ja
also in dem sinn dass in einem erker wie
ein trainingspensum von maximal 20
stunden hatten pro woche und wenn man
nur 20 stunden trainieren darf
dann werden die einheiten relativ
schnell sehr intensiv weil man eben so
wenig zeit wie möglich so viel
intensität einpacken muss wie es geht
noch dazu ist das amerikanische system
ein bisschen anders irgendwie so wenk
quasi also wer schafft der ist oben und
wäre daran zerbricht der geht darunter
der war nicht stark genug
und deswegen war die einheit nicht immer
durch die bank vollgas um mindestens ein
boot nehmen die reinboth links und
rechts damit du dich eben immer menschen
kannst und genauso wie im ergometer gab
es keine einheit wo man nicht nur locker
aus da gemacht hat sondern es wurden
immer zahlen aufgeschrieben das würde
immer vorgehalten und das oder immer
gesenkt und das war einfach die aufgabe
das du quasi immer oben wirst und der
schnellste wirst das geht natürlich
besser wenn man viele menschen hat die
man so aus weilheim auf das sagen das
geht in österreich nicht so gut weil in
österreich kann man damit also wenn wir
fünf sechs sieben leute eingehen auf gut
deutsch dann hast du ein problem weil
dann gibt's nicht mal so viele
und deswegen ist das system in
österreich anders und wir haben mit dem
auch als herr sportler viel mehr zeit
und natürlich auf diesen profisport
vogelschützer gehören der läufer ist ja
nicht nur das olympic ticket heiß
umkämpft es ja auch das ticket für das
verbot in österreich heiß umkämpft wie
darf man sich da den auswahlprozess
vorstellen wer sitzt dann letzten endes
bei den wettkämpfen oder auch bei den
trainings im 4
also letzten endes entscheidet immer der
coach während diesen boten drin sitzt
heuer starten in die neue saison mit
instrumentaler von 14 schwergewichts
männer ruderern und jeder von diesen 14
hat in anspruch an sich selbst oder
glaube ich also ist in diesen vier ohne
reinzukommen dieser vier ohne ist das
gesetz der prime bot also mit dem boot
als da sollten die vier schnellsten drin
sitzen ja uns ähnlich wie wieder fair
gesagt hat also jedes training gilt es
sich zu beweisen jetzt halt nicht immer
auf limit sondern natürlich kann man
sich auch mit technik beweisen
am ende wollen wir dann jeder athlet für
sich selber aber auch der trainer den
schnellsten vier ohne sehen und da wird
dann meistens dann wenn es wenn die
ersten trainingslager vorübergehend dann
so zusammengesetzt wie er dann für die
wettkämpfer fährt manchmal früher
manchmal spielt das hängt auch immer ein
bisschen davon ab wann der ziel
wettkampfes nachdem nächstes jahr schon
im mai die olympische qualifikations
stattfinden wird ist wird das boot
vermutlich schon im februar glaube ich
so zusammensitzen sondern auch fahren
wird damit die abstimmung auch gut passt
dafür
für diejenigen die nicht aus dem
rudersport kommen was ist jetzt ein
vierer ohne ganz genau dadurch genau
also ein vierer ohne heiß quasi vierer
ohne steuermann als wir sitzen zu viert
im boot und wir sind einen riemen
bootsklasse und riemen bedeutet jeder
von uns nur ein ruder in der hand hat es
gibt an backbord und steuerbord oder
also zwei auf steuerbord 2 auf backbord
damit das boot und auch halbwegs gerade
fährt also links und rechts und genau
jeder hat eine ruder in der hand und das
gegenteil davon wäre ein doppelvierer
und das ist auch im vierer nur jeder hat
zwei oder hand also eines kultur- und
wir haben uns spezialisiert auf riemen
also eben jeden rein ruder in der hand
und ja das ist wieder einmal schnell auf
schnell erklärt sowie was der vier
wochen ist dann kann man es auch schnell
wechseln dass man sagt jetzt einmal ein
jahr
der vierer ohne und dann war ich ein
jahr ein doppelfehler geht das oder ist
man dann schon wirklich so technisch
auch spezialisiert dass man da gar nicht
mehr auskommt aus der klasse dann also
wechseln auf von riemen der school nicht
so schnell
vielleicht von scooter freeman ein
bisschen einfacher wenn man mehr
symmetrisch aufgebaut ist aber viele
sagen wenn man mich zum beispiel
oberkörperfrei sieht ist einer seite
erkennbar dicker also muss gelöst als
der anderer seite weil ich eben
einseitig oder aber also ich kann
relativ easy von vier auf zwei switchen
also zweier ohne geht auch noch oder von
vier auf acht
ich bin jetzt kein trainierte einer oder
oder doppelvierer weil mir einfach diese
technische diese jahrelange erfahrung im
schulbereich fehlt und weil ich immer
auch ein bisschen unsymmetrisch bin mit
der muskulatur das würde mir ein paar
ich bräuchte mindestens ein jahr war sie
um mich wieder aufzubauen das ist doch
gar nicht so einfach denn fliegen zu
wechseln das auch vorher schon gesagt
jetzt beide zwei meter große 100 kilo
muskelmasse schwer ist das ein vorteil
für euch die größe die ihr habt so da
kann das dann auch schnell zum nachteil
werden ja also sagt bahn ist ungefähr
gardemaß für schwergewichts oder es gibt
nun auch leichtgewichts oder und das ist
bis maximal 72 5 kilogramm
aber vielleicht habe ich darüber gibt es
keine limits ist minecraft ausdauersport
dass wir unser rennen
normalerweise sechs bis sieben minuten
und deswegen darf man auch nicht zu
schwer sind nicht zu viel muskelmasse
haben die eben auch sauerstoff braucht
alles was eben an muskelmasse oder an
gewicht herumfliegt im boot kann das
boot im aufstellen
also es gibt immer so ein aquarium wo
man eben die perfekten ausmaße hat aber
100 kilometer groß passt endlich
geschafft also jetzt die perfekten
voraussetzungen dafür sei eigentlich zum
rudern gekommen
aber mir war es mehr über umwege also
ich habe eigentlich wir haben viele
sportarten durchprobiert ich bin ein
leidenschaftlicher fußballfan es gibt
doch recht kleine fußball gespielt das
hat mir auch sehr viel spaß gemacht
man hat mich dann leider gottes am knie
verletzt beim fußballspielen und dann
wurde mir gesagt vom arzt und ein gutes
aufbautraining wäre zum beispiel zur
ruder am ruderergometer um mein großer
bruder hat bereits schon zwei jahre
gerudert
und ich habe immer so meinen augen ist
ein bisschen rüber geschickt wäre auch
sehr erfolgreich waren nicht das
eigentlich immer recht spannend fand und
hab dann für aufbautraining eigentlich
begonnen ein bisschen zu rudern am
ruderergometer und habe mich dann auch
in diesem ruderclub beworben wo oben
bruder gerudert und bei mir war es mehr
so in der pubertät und da ist mir
gedacht ja eigentlich ganz cool wenn man
da viel krafttraining machen so dann
schaut man halt übrigens häufig stark
aus und so bin ich da reingerutscht und
ich habe keine ahnung wie ich da
geblieben bin weil irgendwie habe ich
bin ich dann einmal zum training kommen
zweimal dreimal
und plötzlich war ich in diesen ruderer
kreisen drinnen und habe nicht mehr
aufgehört zu tun aber ich habe es
bislang noch nicht bereut und irgendwie
bei umwege und zugfrei bin ich dann auch
da gelandet in diesem wahlkreis und dein
bruder ferdinand hat eine rolle gespielt
wie war das bei dir wie bist du zum gut
angekommen
wir haben auch über umwege also ich habe
eben früher auch sehr viel sport gemacht
ich war immer ein judo basketball
eintrag fußball habe ich mal ein jahr
kein sport gemacht und hat mein vater
gesagt ich brauche dich was du kannst
nicht nur im zimmer sein du kannst nicht
nur bücher lesen du musst eine sport
machen
der präsident von unserem ruderclub
motorclub lee war damals der kurz
anträge seien die und da waren familie
freund hat gewusst dass ich groß bin
mein vater ist auch groß jetzt bringen
wir die jungen zum training und das war
2009 im sommer spätsommer und das
einfach perfekt weil einer alten thoma
was schön warm
wir haben eine halbe stunde ruder sind
nach ins wasser gesprungen war in einer
gruppe von sechs jungen burschen alle
meinem alter und das erste jahr war
einfach sehr locker einfach spaß sich ja
darauf haben wir schon die ersten
regatten gewonnen und danach und nach so
2011-10-12 war hat das training an
relativ regelmässigen professionell
damals schon und die ja wie gesagt also
die sucht und jetzt eine woche lang
mancher trainer nachricht wir morgen
wieder okay morgen wieder und dann am
nächsten tag wieder und dann irgendwann
bist du halt in diesen rhythmus drin und
kann es kaum mehr aufhören weil wir dann
nicht mehr kommst du böse nachricht das
löste auch nicht mittlerweile über 11
jahre und ja funktioniert noch und das
höchst erfolgreich jetzt stelle ich mir
vor dass
mit dem eigenen bruder schon einmal
allgemein dinge natürlich braucht eine
seite schön sein kann auf deiner seite
auch relativ komplex wenn gerade in
seinem brot wo alles funktionieren muss
wenn es einmal kracht oder wenn wenn die
dinge die gerade nicht so funktionieren
wie gehst du damit um rudolf wie
funktioniert das mit einem roboter
gemeinsam die dinge so zu absolvieren ja
also auf eines hat er sicher meine
größten motivator und auf der anderen
seite eine meine größten konkurrenten
wieder moniert eigentlich ganz gut im
boot also und wir werden auch auf
gefragt wer ist der kapitän im boot wer
hat das sagen und gibt es sowas
überhaupt und wir haben alle wissen alle
so so eigenständige leute und haben so
einen starken willen dass ich immer
sagen wir eigentlich gibt es bei uns
keinen kapitän im boot und wir haben
genau das haben wir den coach in der
coach sagt was gemacht wird was richtig
ist was falsch ist und dann halten wir
uns alle natürlich ab und zu krach zu
machen weiß nicht also manchmal geht es
auch gute tage und schlechte tage aber
ich glaube wissen nämlich eine große
bereicherung fürs ganze team wenn mein
bruder hat eine sekunde schneller ist
als ich am ergometer dann möchte ich am
nächsten tag eines unterstandes er
schaukelt sich dann alle so hoch und so
schaffen wir es eigentlich beide glaube
ich wirklich gut eine starke leistungen
zu bringen und stärkten jeder verändert
hat also oder schwächen die rädern hat
durch zum beispiel ausgleich mit meinen
stärken schwächen die ich habe daraus
denkens einstecken also wir haben uns
echt ganz gut und so weit so weit so gut
und so breit was also ist es auch
vorstellbar verdient dass man mal zum
beispiel zwischen euch beiden
entschieden wird wer jetzt im vorsitz
dass zum beispiel noch ein platz frei
ist und dann muss einer von euch immer
das wollte natürlich viel und hat das
training verhindern aber ist das möglich
und wie würde es euch dann gehen und da
wurde jetzt gesagt wissen direkte
konkurrenten das stimmt so gar nicht
weil wir sind ja wie gesagt auf einer
seite spezialisiert und das haben wir
früh genug relativ schlag gelöst dass
ich eben auf backbord für eine arterie
und der aufsteiger auf die andere
das ist um einen eigenen platz kämpfen
wir gar nicht so wirklich natürlich
wollen wir beide ins boot und deswegen
hoffe ich dass wir beide immer in diesem
buch bleiben werden als die beiden
stärksten daran oder schließlich
stärksten ruderer es kann natürlich sein
dass ich es nicht schaffe und der boden
ist oder erst schaffen
im boot bin aber das sagen wir haben uns
nicht gegenseitig herausgehört
hoffentlich hat sie auch eher taktisch
gut überlegt wie er das genau macht wenn
er so in die zukunft jetzt noch schaut
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen über
die sportlichen ziele hinweg was
erwartet euch noch so alles ferdinand du
hast dein studium abgeschlossen
du bist jetzt beim bundesheer was kannst
du dir alles vorstellen in deiner
zukunft
ich würde auch gern ein paar jahre
länger bundes bleiben mal sehen wo mich
meiner sportlichen bewegt ich würde
gerne mindestens einmal zu europäisch
spielen aber eigentlich habe ich den
wunsch eine medaille zu machen
jetzt kann man sagen bei den ersten
olympischen spielen mit einer medaille
schwierig also müssten auch die zweiten
olympischen spielen und danach gibt es
viele möglichkeiten also wo dann ist ein
sport der mann eigentlich bis ins hohe
alter
sportlich ist ihr machen kann also mit
30 ist man immer noch ein sehr guter
ruderer mit 32 ich bin jetzt 24 also ich
hab noch ein paar jahre vor mir
dann haben die eltern in einem betrieb
der mich auch interessieren würde
und vielleicht gibt es in dieser
richtung meine freundin ist kanadierin
vielleicht schlägt sich nach kanada also
es gibt sehr viel offener möglichkeiten
und ich lasse mich dann ein bisschen
bewegen also habe keine präferenz im
moment und verlier über ihre sportliche
ziele habe ich eigentlich recht klare
gesetzt also ich würde gerne nächstes
jahr 2020 zu den olympischen spielen
fahren und dort mal ein bisschen
hineinschnuppern also mal schauen was
technisch möglich ist und zwar jetzt aus
den 24 bei den nächsten spielen in paris
möchte ich schon eine medaille umgehängt
haben weiß dass es mal so der
sportlichen traum nicht mehr so aber es
kann natürlich vieles passieren
dazwischen verletzungen leute haben auch
also ich kann das ja nicht vorhersehen
einfach so so sieht man meinen man
sportlich ein möglicher sportliche
werdegang aus und sonst ja ich möchte
mein studium beenden nicht studiert
sportmanagement
es macht mir sehr viel spaß und ich
möchte auch ein weiterer folge eine
sport treu bleiben und im segment sport
management dann später auch was machen
und aber wie es nach 224 weiter geht
also muss man sich dann gut überlegen
wenn der sport plötzlich aufhört dann
hat man natürlich so ein bisschen ein
loch aber darüber kann ich mich dann
wenn es soweit ist ist ja noch ein
bisschen zeit bis der team danke euch
auf jeden fall fürs kommen zum sportart
alles gute für die zukunft viel
gesundheit und viel erfolg und danken
danken allen
danke danke euch fürs zuhören fürs
dabeisein heute beim sport robot ich
freue mich wenn ihr auch beim nächsten
mal wieder mit dabei sein bis dann
[Applaus]
[Musik]